[Musique]
avec le printemps qu'on a eu toutes ces
inondations il ya des humoristes qui se
réunissent sur scène ce soir à l'olympia
pour un spectacle bénéfice qui
s'intitule nous pour vous vraiment un
événement qui vise à amasser des fonds
pour venir en aide aux sinistrés des
inondations qui ont frappé le québec au
cours des dernières semaines s'est
animée par rachid badouri plusieurs
humoristes dont rosalie vaillancourt qui
sera sur scène et avec nous ce matin
bonjour vous allez jouer votre auto ce
matin pour se lever
ça va c'est quand même tout oui là donc
ce soir
quel est le concept du spectacle mais en
fait c'est vraiment un concept de télé
stand up et chacun va faire son numéro
d'environ 8 9 minutes et on est craint
donc savamment est un mini mélodies mort
est différent donc c'est vraiment
intéressant pour les gens qui aiment
vraiment beaucoup l'humour et qui
veulent voir des choses qui voit pas
nécessairement en somme c'est la
deuxième fois que vous faites ça parce
que en 2017 il y avait eu une initiative
du genre en le spectacle avec des
humoristes
puis il y avait réussi à amasser au
dessus des 43 mille dollars donc on
espère ce soir qu'on veut dépasser c'est
tout l'argent est remis à la croix-rouge
canadienne puis les humoristes vous le
faites vraiment de bon coeur sans cacher
tout ça c'est aussi gratuite va pas été
en fait c'est une façon pour nous de
redonner un peu à la société si c'est là
la seule chose qu on peut faire mousser
ses nativement ont donc si on peut le
faire sans cacher par une soirée ben je
pense pas que ça change grand chose à
notre vie avez vous été témoin dans
votre entourage se faisaient la tournée
j'ai vu beaucoup de classe étaient
inondés puis 6 c'est très très satisfait
hier c'est quelque chose puisse en fait
y en a encore qui sont sinistrés en ce
moment en question on oublie un peu vite
comme on n'a même pas moins parler de
paix les deux dernières semaines pour ça
que c'est fun qu'on le fasse un mot
après que ça a commencé parce que le ça
redonne un peu d'attention médiatique
sur son lit vraiment parce que les gens
ont encore besoin d'indicés de bénévoles
vont les aimer avec vous alexandre
barrette françois bellefeuille
a mis en écoute sur les dix ong du
temple et j'en passe je l'avais fait
quoi bon et très bon comme spectacle ce
qui reste des billets à ce que vous le
savez non c'est sur le dirt et toutes
été vendues
on est vraiment contents les gens ayant
vraiment beaucoup participé 5 sur un an
fin oui c'est bien parce que les
sinistrés vont recevoir justement tout
cet argent via la croix rouge canadienne
il ya pénélope mcquade qui vient de nous
écrit rosalie pour nous annoncer un
scoop vous allez faire partie de son
émission à la radio dès septembre
mais en fait ça à la télévision s'est
fait manger je pense que ça s'appelle we
reste un concept de sketches comment
être présentés à des invités exactement
les actifs disent qu'est ce que trouve
drôle donc ça peut être moins chaud et
c'est drôle et ce que j'ai harvey au
choix ça drôle la poule me fait rire
mais là j'ai essayé de trouver un sketch
qui rassemble ces deux univers le entre
que c'est vraiment éclatés donc une
nouvelle mairie tape dans la carrière
puis ce nom pour l'été on vous voit où
l'on offrait à moncheaux enfant roi qui
est qu'ils aient place un peu partout
peluches en résidence à valleyfield
pièces intéressent et était d'engager
avoir pas mal de téléphone avec les
jeunes c'est excellent dessinateur vous
allez vaillancourt merci de venir voir
ce soir sur scène à l'olympia avec bien
d'autres humoristes et s'est animé je
vous rappelle par arracher de badouri et
c'est pour les sinistrés des inondations
merci bien et ça fera plaisir au revoir